my old man told me when i was younger
like right when i first turned pro he's
like you got one shot at this yeah he's
like you're going to snap your fingers
and you're going to be old beat up okay
and your time's going to be over so he's
like don't live with any regret and give
it 100 at all times and that was 100 on
the dirt bike that was 100 in partying
and enjoying myself there's nothing
worse than life than living with regret
[Music]
you're gonna find out like very soon uh
you know that there's a reason why i'm
i'm i'm paid to
[ __ ] say written lines you know
making up my own it's like not my not my
strong suit it's all right i'm a stupid
dirt bike rider so yeah dude it's
[ __ ] it's it's great i do my best
work with the helmet on oh my god
coming out to your place and and and
meeting you and sort of not just seeing
your setup but just the the feeling
there and meeting big and and uh you
know man i just immediately connected to
you and like just had like respect you
know we just immediately just started
yeah kids and and family so yeah um
that's kind of the idea it's cool in
this day and age to align with people
because it gets a little trickier i know
man you know i know would you say you've
endured more injuries than any elite
professional athlete in in the world oh
absolutely i mean there's like nothing
like it right i was just the doctor
yesterday i thought i blew my nail last
week how the [ __ ] i got a tour torment
my meniscus and sprained my mcl
just exiting a turn caught my toe
happened that fast spun my foot
backwards so you're on a [ __ ]
motorcycle you're taking and what this
is started yet huh it doesn't matter
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but like you're just riding for pleasure
well so uh i think as i told you i had a
disc replacement my neck and my back in
in uh in the fall and i've been back on
my bike two weeks and honestly it's just
a bad day at the office that's the [ __ ]
that happens i was
turning laps i was exiting a turn i put
my foot back on the peg to charge down
the straightaway and a little clump
caught my toe and spun my foot backwards
and luckily it didn't pop but i saw that
white white flash which i'm sure you've
seen before through boxing and
rode around for another half lap i'm
like oh man this is not good yeah and
anyways hobbled around for a week i
finally got a hold of my knee specialist
and went down yesterday and small small
um meniscus tear in a mcl sprain but no
surgery and i'll be back on my bike in
two weeks come hell or high water but to
answer your question you know not to
take anything away from any other sport
i mean being the top of the of the totem
pole in any professional sport is a huge
accomplishment but
unfortunately motocrosses we just take a
beating i mean i've broken i'm in the
high 80s now for broken bones
i've had 19 surgeries
i can't tell you how many injections and
experimental medications i've had shot
into my body to try to you know patch me
up and get me back on my bike yeah yeah
so it's
it's the black eye of the sport you know
and now we're starting to learn a lot
about athletes having concussion
syndrome i mean i know i definitely have
elements of it yeah i think that's what
kind of leads what are you seeing like
what are you feeling um you know as i
get older i don't know if it's due to
like you know responsibility of children
age you know compounded with concussions
over the years but you know i get a
little stressed a little easier a little
more anxious okay and
you know i i know that it's there i mean
i've had some pretty serious bell
ringers and i've had unfortunately i've
had friends that have you know committed
suicide due to it and so i'm just trying
to kind of keep keep my marbles together
and know that that is a piece of it and
deal with it and move forward positively
as opposed to getting immersed by it so
your big injury
that happened i mean you've had lots of
big [ __ ] injuries
like what you were 16 years old
and it was before it was before you
turned pro yeah so what you're talking
about was um it was it happened when i
was 15 years old i was going into my
last uh amateur national race about to
turn pro
and i was out at the actual racetrack
when they were having the last amateur
national at um just so happens my old
man and his company were building the
track
and they called me out to do some lap
times it was a brand new track and so i
came out i geared up uh my old man told
all those guys to take lunch me and
another guy were going to go out and do
a few laps so they could get kind of lap
times to figure out how long to run the
run the motors
i geared up jumped on my bike took off
down the start straight away it was me
and a buddy of mine richard we were kind
of side by side and there's a section
the track was a big sweeping
right-hander and on the inside of the
turn they were kind of dropping big
piles of topsoil so my buddy rich kind
of rolled over the inside and i railed
the outside and there was a big probably
like three story tall big tabletop jump
and i came around the outside and hit
that take off and literally as i came
off i saw a uh scraper backing up the
back side of the hill [ __ ] like tr uh
uh a [ __ ] like big [ __ ] massive
coming at you coming at me he was on the
center of the track
the fir you know you know my first
reaction in the air is i threw the bike
sideways i literally landed in between
the back tires and the scraper is the
one that has that big belt in the middle
with that it's called the stinger on the
back i hit right at the stinger
flipped me over the handlebars i landed
in front of the tire i looked down both
my legs were broken they were folded mid
thigh my feet my kneecaps were under my
butt my feet were behind me
and uh
i'm sitting on the ground and i looked
up and the literally the wheel is right
i'm sitting right in front of the wheel
the operator panics and jumps out
because he felt me hit the tractor he
didn't set the emergency brake the
tractor starts skidding down the hill i
put my hands up to block my face
my dad just barely swooped me out got me
out of the way but i compounded my femur
i was bleeding out
tourniquet on my leg rushed me to the
hospital and yeah i ended up breaking um
both femurs one in five places one and
six compounded one of them uh broke my
tib fib on my right leg folded up folded
that in half and then on both of my arms
and and like your pot like your [ __ ]
and like your dad your dad was there he
built that for you right like i mean i
really want to like just talk about your
dad but like your dad i mean he saved
your life he pulled you out of that
situation like what the [ __ ] was that
like for him i mean have you guys talked
about that
you know that that's actually a bigger
conversation we get we can get into um
but yeah you know it was it was just
treacherous for him you know like not
only having that happen
i almost bled out on the way the
hospital i almost didn't make to the
hospital because i was just bleeding out
so bad you know going through the
surgery process the doctor want to take
my leg off immediately
he begged the doctor to at least stitch
it back together and see if my leg will
hold because they thought my leg had
died
and you know through that process you
know it was extremely traumatic and but
you know to kind of circle it back
around you know that's what i did like i
was on the trajectory at 15 years old
i've been writing since i was four years
old racing since i was five
racing at a very serious level since i
was 12 and looking to go pro and do this
for a living right so that mental
capacity at 15 years old that this is my
career trajectory this is what i'm going
to do for the rest of my life like you
you got to take the good with the bad
you know you got to take your licks and
keep moving forward and to me at 15 that
was just another lick is there any
second where you're like dude [ __ ] this
man like that like this is this is
insane you know what i tell people is uh
you know it's a little different with
youth you know you bounce you get back
you feel quicker but
you know when you're laying in the dirt
in any major injury like that you're
like oh my god why the [ __ ] do i do this
i'm you know this isn't worth it and you
go through this process right and you're
in surgery and then you're in recovery
and then you're home on the couch
but much as your body heals those
memories kind of fade out
so much about motocross i would say any
action sports and again i'm never taking
anything away from traditional ball
sports but
you know
i will ride a dirt bike until i can no
longer breathe or walk tony hawk will
skateboard whether he's getting a
paycheck or not i don't know if joe
montana plays two-hand touch on the
weekend but action sports people it's
it's not about money because going back
to those days none of us made money
right i mean money only came into action
sports in like
early 2000's and you weren't a
professional yet no and i wasn't
supposed to this was this was a plan
this was a drive and where and where do
you think that that comes from um i
think it's just the competitive drive in
motocross because
i was again comparing apple's apples you
know a traditional team sport
you know you're kind of doing it for fun
and it's probably not so much about the
win when you're in t-ball or playing you
know
uh minor league baseball at 12 13 years
old but you know racing motocross it's
it's competition at its best i mean you
start by that gate drop and the first
one across the finish line is the winner
so that kind of need for competition is
ingraining you at such a young age
while you're just doing it from a fun
standpoint because you know just like
anything you you're gonna you know if
you're playing baseball some of the kids
care about winning and some of them
don't and that's just kind of probably
what separates the two but for me as a
motocross writer starting to race at
five you know getting a little bit
better by six seven years old i wanted
to win each weekend i mean yeah i was
out there with my friends i was out
there with my old man but you know that
that need to win is ingrained at you at
a very young age so what was ingrained
into you into me yeah into you i mean i
guess that's my question it's like and
again like not not really having like a
real like thorough understanding of the
sport like look man i can give you a
hundred examples of guys who are [ __ ]
beast baseball guys i know who could you
go in a boxing gym they can fight their
asses off but you get them into a fight
and they get their ass beat one time and
they're like yo i'm done with this
forever yeah or you get hit by one pitch
or
and and it changes the gears yeah yeah
is there any of that do you feel like
have you seen guys get shook
absolutely i mean you know a lot of
people don't have there there is a
mental switch you have to have like in
in what i do and especially
getting to that top tier it's not if
it's when you crash and it's not if it's
when you have a serious injury and you
have to have that mental switch and if
at any given point you lose that switch
it's too dangerous to do and you can't
do it anymore or you can't do it at the
level that you're doing it and i've i've
had to kind of really chase that switch
a handful of times i mean i mean we're
talking about that one injury like that
was my first major injury but i broke
both of my legs in both my arms at the
same time twice multiple times yeah you
know i shattered my heel and broke a
femur on tony hawk's tour right because
i had to i had to make a split decision
as i'm going up a ramp and one of the
skaters popped out on the deck in front
of me
okay am i going to go into the crowd or
am i just going to sacrifice myself and
jump into the vert ramp and i jumped
into the vert ramp and destroyed me and
that was the second time i almost died
from it i mean blood clots and you know
pinched arteries and icu for almost a
month in a wheelchair for four months
after that you know like there's just a
switch you have to have and if you lose
that switch then it's time to do it for
fun or
move along and i think that's kind of
what separates
i guess the people that stick with it
and you know they can push through the
injuries and the people that can't for
you what what is the emotional kind of
um effect of when when you literally
like can't use your when your body is
like you you can't use your body is that
like how would you describe that is that
fear is that is it frustration is it
everything like it's everything it's
absolutely torturous you know because i
am a very physical person you know like
uh
you know when i'm laid up i mean that
that's why i'm so hard-headed in my
recovery you know like we've talked
about a little bit you know i've i have
a major surgery
two more two more winners from now and
i've already had three the last three
winters and
my my mental focus is to get through it
as fast as possible go into it in the
best shape as possible is that where you
were at 15. did you have that attitude
15. so you already had sort of a
professional athletes mentality at 15
and and was it different at 15 than when
you're already you know on tony hawk's
like it was different at 15 because it's
it's probably like you and your career
is that carrots dangled in front of you
right and like i want to get to be i
want to get to that level so i got to
get through this injury as quickly as
possible so i can get back on the
amateur circuit earn my points and get
enough points to turn pro and like so i
i had that carrot dangled in front of me
because i wanted to make that platform
and then once you get to that platform
you got to maintain it okay and it does
get a little trickier you know like
now as a you know legitimate
professional athlete with endorsements
coming in now it's like okay i got to
get through this injury quickly because
i have an injury clause in my contract
if i'm off my bike too long i lose my
contract right and that's paying my
mortgage and that's paying for my
lifestyle
and when you're 15 what's the first i
mean like what's the first thing like
[ __ ] i'm not i mean does that even enter
into your brain like i'm not going to
attain my dream like i'm on this track
and i'm not going to get there or
absolutely it is it is oh it's a huge
fear because with motocross we don't
have off season right you know we race
you know race compete whatever whatever
discipline you're doing i mean it's 52
weeks a year and
being sidelined for six months the
progression rate is so fast especially
as an amateur you can miss your window
and technically i kind of did miss my
window like looking back in the grand
scheme of things you know i don't i
don't want to say i was a prodigy by any
means but i was a really good am and i
was set to turn pro my 16th birthday and
my natural trajectory is like okay
hopefully i'll get onto a good team a
factory ride and just go through the
ranks but that three month four four
month setback of not writing held me
back as i am one more year and i you
know i think everything happens for a
reason
i mean even getting into the tony hawk
tour injury but that trajectory slowed
me down into the pro ranks i was a
completely average pro supercross racer
at best but that's also what made me
pivot halfway through my motocross
career from being a racer into focusing
on freestyle motocross right so
everything does happen for a reason but
you're constantly in that mindset of i
gotta get healthy because either the
wagon's gonna pass me or i gotta get
healthy so i can keep my contract or i
gotta get healthy for the next big
contest but dude i am [ __ ] convinced
that this is only with you man because
like you you know i i like dude your
your your career is [ __ ] unbelievable
and it it's like this work ethic and
this [ __ ] drive where does your pops
what role does he play just talk a
little bit about about about him and the
way you you grew up well that's what's
pretty interesting you know about my
upbringing and you know like i'm not
going to say my life was hard but
you know my old man was 23 years old
when i was born my mom was out of the
picture and he was a just entry level
construction worker he made 35 grand a
year raising a newborn and a child on
his own through my entire child period
and you know as motocross got serious
for me
you know
he was always very adamant about
you know school
he's like i i will support i will
leverage every
everything i have to support your
motocross career but if you don't have
a's and b's those motorcycles are parked
i don't care how good you are i don't
care what race is coming up and that was
how life was you know so through my
whole school career you know it was a's
and b's wrote the bikes were parked
right and in hindsight
it was the best thing he could have done
for me and there were two times where my
bike was parked until the next report
card and that never happened again but
because of that work ethic you know you
get back to work ethic i had to have
that work ethic in school and the other
you know the other contingency was if
you're not giving 100 on your motorcycle
i'm not going to waste my money you know
he works way too hard i mean there was
times where we wouldn't have power so
that we had money for entry fees at my
next motocross race or we didn't have
you know hot water and gas because i
needed a new bike for the next race
season you as a as a dad now do you
carry that same line absolutely 100
absolutely and so it's like if you're
going to be doing something you do it
100 or you're not doing it but yeah i do
because and i'm sure you can appreciate
this the tricky part is is
you know my kids aren't going to
experience my upbringing meaning oh man
am i going to have hot water tonight for
a shower or oh [ __ ]
are the lights going to be on or oh [ __ ]
is my old man going to come home from
the bar tonight you know like my kids
aren't going to experience that so i
have to be hard on them in their work
ethic and their follow-through and
committing to things because i don't
want my kids to be raised spoiled little
brats and my kids aren't going to suffer
the way that i do right you got to put
adversity in their lives exactly that's
part of the responsibility of being a
dad if it's exactly so do you think
history that that sort of mandate if
you're going to be out there you're
going 100 you're not going to be out
there do you think that's to teach you a
life lesson or do you think that's to
make you the best of what you can be in
motocross do you think it's all the
above like
just tell me about like kind of him and
his heart i think it was a life lesson
truthfully because
look me and him both knew at me at a
very young age it's i mean it's one
percent that makes it to that top level
and of that one percent there's probably
five percent of that one percent that
actually make enough money to live on
you know again this was a passion thing
but he wanted to instill that work
you know that work level and work
respect into me because you know he's
always told me he's like you don't want
to swing a shovel for a living it's
[ __ ] miserable and you know to this
day i will go rob banks before i shovel
asphalt like my old man does yeah and it
was putting that work ethic in me
that obviously helped me through my
motocross career but more importantly
through the rest of my life whether
that's the businesses that i started
whether that's the commitment to my kids
and my wife was commitments to my
friends you know like you have to have
that work ethic and that drive
especially nowadays and um i mean that
was the biggest gift and biggest life
lesson i got through how hard he was on
me through those years and don't get me
wrong i mean like
he he would have no problem telling me
if i had a shitty race or if i was
riding like a [ __ ] [ __ ] or you
know if my intensity wasn't there but
the the lessons that i got from that you
know just like anything like you can
tell somebody you know the quickest way
from a to b is this line but sometimes
they gotta learn it for themselves and
that was my my learning lessons you
primarily grew up in vegas right i mean
can you can you just kind of like
describe like big what like what that
was like what because i think people
have an idea of
of vegas and and uh
people i know who actually grew up there
can you just talk about sort of like
your vegas and the vegas you came up in
it was great you know i was there from
79 until i guess uh oh through or o5 of
ivish and it was great i mean that town
at that time it was
less than a hundred thousand people yeah
and for what i did and my passions were
it was great you know it was great for
mile man for the the construction
business and i had nothing but desert to
ride in and
you know this the tricky thing about
vegas is you kind of go down two paths
you know you either you're productive
and you take something away positive
from living in that town or as you can
imagine you go the wrong path and you
get you know locked up on the strip and
drugs booze anything in between yeah and
for me it was a really positive
environment because i had this athlete
mentality at a very young age you know i
didn't drink in high school i didn't
party i didn't i didn't have the
opportunity to do all those things so
for me it was really positive and so
when your dad sees sort of the
environment you're growing up in do you
think that that was a big part of his
reason of sort of putting the push that
he put on i mean was it was that also it
yeah i do think so because you know my
family tree from my grandfather to my
dad my uncles myself you know there's a
lot of the other path there there was
there was a total ability to choose the
other path [ __ ] you know and i know
that well my grandpa was a scrapper and
a rough guy and my old man was the same
way and i have those tendencies as well
yeah and it you know and i think it was
probably very beneficial for my old man
to have this tool this little carrot to
take it away yeah it's like do you step
out of line yeah it's gone yep and you
know i i hope i can have that care for
my kids one day kids aren't telling me
to [ __ ] off you know because it's pretty
easy to do yeah but uh it was it was
definitely helpful and and how good like
how good of a how good of a rider like
how good is he so i i was the only my
it's funny like my grandfather used to
ride dirt bikes my dad rode my uncle's
road um none of them for you know
serious just just for fun you know they
all grew up in southern california and
that was the thing to do back in the 60s
and 70s and you know
we didn't go to baseball games we went
to you know the rose bowl super cross
like you know our we were a very
motorcycle uh interested family so
that's why you know for my fourth
christmas under the tree was a dirt bike
and that was just our angle like and
then my grandfather used to come to
every race with us on the weekend you
know like that was our weekend me and my
old man would leave my house and stop by
and pick up my grandpa he'd be out there
with his ice chest and already a
six-pack deep at seven o'clock in the
morning and we'd go out to the motocross
track all weekend so like you're love
you loving it you loving it early and
and i imagine like being good at it i
mean like that must have been just great
for him i mean that must have been i
mean was that part of it too just like
seeing how proud it made him and and how
happy it made him definitely you know
because that was our bonding time
because my old man he worked 60 hours a
week right you know like i would i would
have to wake myself up in the morning
you know he would call me and at seven
o'clock when scooby-doo's on and i had
to get myself out the door to school and
back home and cook myself dinner a lot
of the times so the weekends were ours
to go racing and that's where we spent
our quality time yeah and we got to
experience this together you know like
he
what little he knew about motocross you
know he tried to pass on to me and a lot
of it was trial and error but uh that
was our bonding experience and i would
race 40 45 weekends a year so that was
our routine and we got to have that
quality time yeah he knew
how close i was to death i could only
imagine what it was like for him to go
through i mean i was in the hospital for
like 10 days
you know in traction and my with two
broken femurs and all this crazy [ __ ]
and uh yeah i couldn't imagine what he
went through honestly like it had been
absolutely gut wretching and it would
have been really easy for him to slam
the gavel and be like okay we're done
with this i'm never going to go i'm
personally never going to go through
that again yeah but uh but he was
extremely you know i got out of the
hospital and after do you think he felt
that at all though like oh i'm sure i'm
i'm how could he know how can you not
exactly you know and uh yeah to go
through that and then to still have the
support for me you know because we let a
couple of weeks go by and that that big
race i was getting ready to do i was out
there in my wheelchair with my broken
legs and watching the class you know i
was supposed to be racing in and a
couple of weeks later we talked about
he's like so you know what do you want
to do from here and i'm like i'm going
to get as healthy as fast as possible
and i think i can get back and do the
winter series and he's just like
all right well put in the work and put
in the work and i was back on my bike
for the winter series but you know but
then before fast forward my old man had
to watch my brother die from a motocross
accident and it's like you know it's
just dude absolutely gut wrenching it's
hard i couldn't imagine it when you're
when your brother passed was that before
or after the the tony hawk crash um my
brother passed
god i guess it's been about 11 years now
so it was it was fo it was after that um
me and my brother were 12 years apart
right so i wasn't in the house too much
with my brother i was basically out of
the house at about 16. but um yeah i had
to watch my dad go through it all over
again with uh with my brother which
eventually
i think my dad went through such a major
break with it like we don't talk anymore
because it was just such a you know it's
you know no one's supposed to bury their
kid right and he had to go through that
and it was just gut-wrenching for him
and he had to live that all over again
and uh and
i mean if you don't mind me asking like
where do you think that that where do
you think that that comes from like you
guys not being able to um you know i i
think it comes from you know me and my
dad were so close and it was always just
me and him
and then you know he remarried
uh you know him and his wife had my
brother and it was just a different
dynamic and i think my dad and my
brother weren't as close as me and him
were
they had a lot of
kind of personal issues like my brother
didn't have the drive that i had and it
was probably it was probably very
frustrating for him and i think with my
brother passing
all that guilt
all that emotion just flipped just
flipped the switch and it became this
very uncomfortable dynamic where you
know like you know anthony's living in
my shadow and we weren't there from them
and it's like no that's actually not the
case and it just kind of snowballed yeah
and you know i just at the end of the
day even though we don't talk i have all
the compassion in the world for what
he's gone through and you know that that
little bit of
you know resentment i hold back because
it's like dude no one's supposed to go
through that totally it's like the one
thing that we know i think yeah for sure
it's like if you have a kid it doesn't
matter whether you're near far
you know talking not talking that love
is like unbreakable and yeah so like
unbelievably profound and undeniable the
the lessons that he instilled in me
until you know the day that i became a
man and was out the door and living my
life on my own i mean that's what made
me you know you know similarly i think
just like with my old man i mean there's
just like an it's a generational thing
it's just it's a hardness and i'm like
those things that were like [ __ ] man you
know
that's pretty rough dude it's like now
i'm i'm uh enormously grateful for them
yeah and there's no way i could be doing
what i do
without that um
what kind of data are you
ah well truthfully with my daughter roma
pushover me too because it's yeah it's
the only girl you know
but we have a very uh
personality wise we're very very similar
so uh
good she's much like me introvert you
know not too extroverted uh very intense
very uh competitive very physical very
driven like give me an example of her
competitiveness
when she was younger it was like like
teaching her how to ride a bicycle right
sounds pretty uh pretty simple i would
kind of teach her things and she would
just be like no i got this i got this
and then she would go off and hide
somewhere and practice and figure it out
yeah and then come show me like look
what i did yeah yeah like she did you
know like in that that competitive
streak in her and now it's like whether
it's skiing or wake surfing or any sport
that she does i mean if she's not like
she races bmx and if she's not you know
if she's not podium top three going home
with a trophy she is so hard on herself
yep yeah and it's just that and it's
like said like i can't explain why i had
at such a young age why i can't i can't
explain that she does cause i don't push
for competitiveness or doing sports like
i want to introduce them to everything
but she just has that ingrained in her
and then and that's it man it's like you
either have that or you don't but yeah
that that sort of like desire and like
that sort of innate kind of like natural
instinct to go get in the [ __ ] lab
and like yeah that's not working so i'm
gonna go like privately and whatever
that is whether it's like embarrassment
yeah whether whatever the [ __ ] it is
that's driving you yeah and and it's
interesting man because i know
i know for me that kind of came later in
life like for me i found that in a
specific thing but now i can kind of
apply it to others because i don't know
i i don't know the same with your kids
my kids are all so [ __ ] different
like i yeah you know some of them just
like you know one of them
has that so specifically almost to the
point where it's like yo dude you need a
[ __ ]
yeah and then the other one's like you
got to put you know just so you know
laughing his way through everything
which is also yeah kind of beautiful and
and and i think um and then i have a uh
you know my daughter's just kind of the
same she can do whatever the [ __ ] she
wants she's just like
you know she just is so incredible but
but but i guess um i get that thing
about like trying to put adversity in
the kids lives and and challenges
because you know our our kids are are
growing up quite differently than we
grew up how do you feel like you do that
um it's just i i would say the number
one big one is follow-through you know
like whether that's an activity they
want to join you know it's like if you
hate it well you got to finish it out
you got to you got to see every step of
the way through it then it's just you
know then it could be stupid [ __ ] you
know
doing your chores cleaning up your room
whatever it may be but then it's also
like when they're spending time with me
like they both love to ride motocross i
never want to push them in the direction
of racing but i built them a track at my
house
it's like hey all right if we're going
to ride you got to check over your
motorcycle we got to go pull weeds on
the track when we're done riding we're
going to rake the track and get off the
rocks off of it and you have to see
everything all the way through yeah you
know like there's no whining you know
like you've been to my shop there's no
crying there's no whining in my shop you
do that [ __ ] go to the house and it's
just like setting those kind of you know
benchmarks for them you know we go to
the lake okay guys we're down at the
lake get up in the boat start drying
everything down because that's the only
way if i don't at least start teaching
them those fundamentals now
you know as well as anybody they're not
gonna learn in their teens or their
twenties it's like a huge problem right
now because like everybody wants their
kids to be i mean i think there is this
attitude of like hey you want your kids
to sort of like grow up better than you
or you want you but like you got it's a
slippery slope it is
it's like you you know there's there's
such uh
you you know such passivity right now
and
that's running rampant and you gotta you
know it's like if if not us who else is
gonna do it you know what i mean and
it's hard to swallow because it's now
starting to translate into
team sports and school and all this
other [ __ ] where it's like you know
everyone gets a trophy and everything
you know all this [ __ ] and it's like
dude if people haven't learned yet life
isn't easy life is [ __ ] hard and
you're setting these kids up for failure
by not giving them the opportunity to
lose and to get hungry and motivated for
something or getting a bad grade
i mean i i can't wrap my head around it
and and and you know you mentioned like
team just i think like youth sports in
general right now it's something i think
about all the time like raising athletes
and i heard you say that that you never
really did this for medals and and
you've already brought up just sort of
like the financials of it like that you
never really did that you know you love
it you do it because you love it yeah um
i mean you [ __ ] you know you [ __ ]
flipped a motorcycle you know what i
mean like no one you know and then like
that changed the whole
game but like just that drive it was
like this this thing that you just were
not would not let go i guess like you
couldn't do what you did if this wasn't
your dream if it wasn't what you wanted
to do um
you know how do you awaken that in the
kid um i think my answer to that is is
first and foremost i want to i want to i
want my kids to experience everything
you know i want them to
try things i know nothing about like my
my daughter just fell in love with
tennis cool i go play tennis with her we
have a great time playing tennis i'm
terrible but we have fun doing it you
know
got my kids into water sports but i
think it's it's a little bit of a
slippery slope i think that
on one hand
all the freebies and all the
participation trophies and you know
there's no winner today i don't think
that's setting a great example or a
model or a drive for anybody because me
and my youth if i didn't you know it's
not like i put my leg over a motorcycle
at four and i started winning everything
right i got my ass kicked for years and
years and years until you know i cut my
teeth and without that drive of losing
and not getting that trophy you know not
standing on top of the box what would
have been my drive why do you want to
try harder then if there is no winner
what's the motivation to get better
right you know but then there's the flip
side which i see happening in motocross
right now with all the private coaching
and
you know
not having breaks i i think there's
something really cool again about you
know traditional stick and ball sports
where you can play baseball for the
season and then that same that same kid
can go play football and he can do water
polo like now where everything is so
immersive where you get to pick one
sport at 12 years old and you have to
stick with that it's crazy how do you
know what is actually going to be your
strong suit when you have to make such a
commitment so young and it feels like
it's a cash grab crazy you know like why
is why does a kid who want to just wants
to play soccer has to do travel soccer
and do 60 matches a year
all year [ __ ] long so
that's just the kind of like the i think
kids need the nudge and the push i think
that's healthy
but i also think they need the
opportunity to try a bunch of things
because i what i want my kids to do that
i didn't just from having maybe a little
bit fuller life because who knows what i
maybe missed out on
is to do a broad spectrum of things and
if they are physical or like my daughter
right now like maybe it's acting
whatever it might be but if she can't
figure that out until she's 16 17 i
don't want her to miss out on that
opportunity because i made her play
tennis at 12. right right because she's
shown some talent for it and she's so
yeah and and and i mean like who it's
very rare i mean it's very rare that and
and and i think sometimes it has to do
more with a lack of opportunity look man
like what was that in front of you and
that's all i noticed that's what you
exactly and you had this [ __ ] drive
like let's go but um i think it's hugely
i mean my kid you know he plays
you know he's like playing multiple
travel sports i'm like dude three years
ago he was [ __ ] his pants like he's
running around literally with a pamper
full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
full of [ __ ] and like now it's like some
professional coach it's like his
livelihood depends on my kids games
whether he wins or not so i'm like dude
shut the [ __ ] you know what i mean and
that's the part i have a problem with
it's insane man like i played college
but i didn't pick up a baseball glove
until i was 12. like i was like doing
other [ __ ] exactly and uh and you know i
mean just like i think parenthood in
general man we just we so want to get it
right and we're so just definitely not
going to no you know it's like it's the
only job you know you're going to [ __ ]
up absolutely you know what i mean but
yeah just like keep trying you keep
going you got to admit your mistakes and
you got to be there and
as a young competitor
what was like the culture like how has
it changed and like where it is like
money and like when money comes into it
i've heard you talk a little bit about
it but i'm just really interested about
it in your mind and how much that can
sort of like [ __ ] things up and and how
much it can be a driver
yeah it's it's funny you say that
because uh you know really looking at
the specific part of my career being
freestyle motocross which you know got
serious for myself and my group of
buddies that you're talking about you
know back in 96 97 you know it's much
like if you've ever seen that that movie
uh dog town and z boys yeah yeah it's
very similar to that you know
we're we're all young we're 20 you know
20 22 23
starting to make a little bit of money
you know getting some attention for
doing goofy trip tricks on our dirt bike
you know stealing bmx tricks and doing
them on dirt bikes
but that camaraderie that we all had you
know it was
you know like to your point you know we
all rode together there's a group of
about 15 guys that when this whole thing
kind of started and we were all racers
who were sick of the politics of racing
and we found this new niche you know and
motocross videos were getting popular
and the girls loved the motocross video
so of course we love that
and you know we just we all just kind of
raised hell together you know we would
ride during the week together and kind
of push each other
we'd be on a plane going and doing a
contest that weekend and yeah you know
everybody wanted to win but and i
imagine living like [ __ ] maniacs
absolutely [ __ ] lunatics you know man
i i often think about like you know the
guys that i came up with if if me and my
friends hit it at a young like i don't
know that i'd be a lot there's just no
way that that guy could hand there's no
way that you could what i've heard about
you guys is it was sort of that it was
like that perfect storm of like you guys
hit it and and and you were you were you
were that
and and so like yeah like what can you
can you describe it can you sort of like
describe what that lifestyle was like
yeah i mean it was complete chaos you
know like there was this period of time
from
you know call like 96 until you know 0
203
where
we were just you know we were inventing
new stuff on a dirt bike weekly and we
got all this influx of attention and and
really you know in a big fish in a small
pond fame
and you know we were getting flown all
over the world to do contests and as
hard as we rode we partied even harder
and it was just it was a it was a time
like all you know probably the easiest
way to explain it you know there's this
time in like 98 99 2000 where we would
go to australia and they would do this
tour called the krusty tour and keep in
mind it's eight american 20 year old 25
year old motocross riders
and
it was this kind of choreographed tour
it's kind of cheesy whatever but
motocross was massive in australia and
i'm going to totally date myself on this
um the last tour that we all did
together um
we were out selling stadiums faster than
limp bizkit and the kiss the kiss finale
tour was okay so we were like national
treasures over there at this time
and you know we would show we would roll
into town and you know we'd go do our
autograph signings and do some
promotions
we would go through blow through the
show i mean just complete carnage you
know destroying motorcycles in the show
and you know inciting people to come and
rush the floor and you know causing
riots and all this [ __ ] and then we go
back into the dressing room and
whatever your choice was if it was drugs
booze girls it was all waiting for you
in the dressing room and we would
completely trash the dressing room and
then it was a race to get to the hotel
and we would get to the hotel and in our
rider we had to be in the best hotels
i'll never forget this we were at the uh
i think it was the four seasons in
melbourne
and everybody checks in and everybody
starts checking in in a different
writer's name
so we just started grabbing keys and we
ended up flooding the entire top floor
of the four seasons hotel throwing
furniture out of the 18 story window
onto a grass tennis court before so
obviously you know through your project
what that what that's like and just we
we cause a quarter million dollars in
damage on a six-week tour wow but the
promoter was just scratching checks
because what he was getting at the shows
and this whole persona followed us
through each city yeah and it just got
crazier and crazier and
i mean it's it's a it's a snapshot in
time as to
what life was like as as each of us
individually in our career trajectory
going from no one knew us two and a half
years earlier to this you know chaos
and then to your point you know then the
money starts coming in and not that i
don't think there's anything super
negative but guys just started to kind
of take on their own role you know i got
a little bit serious about my career
it's like okay you know there's a time
to party there's a time to get serious
and i took the serious role as well as a
handful of other guys and some of the
other guys unfortunately couldn't let
the party go and that was slowly the
demise of their career do you go back to
sort of thinking about your dad and all
the sacrifices he made you think about
like what it is like what your goals
were was it a specific goal that you
were trying to sort of achieve that that
you realize that like living that way
wouldn't wha what like how do you get
there um you know my old man told me
when i was younger like right when i
first turned pro
and he meant this from a lot of
different categories he's like you got
one shot at this yeah he's like you're
going to snap your fingers and you're
going to be old and beat up and your
time's going to be over so he's like
don't live with any regret and give it a
hundred percent at all times yeah and
that was 100 on the dirt bike that was
100 in partying and enjoying myself that
was 100
at providing for my sponsors and making
a career out of it and i think that's
really where it came from because it's
like you have to you have one shot at it
and that's it and there's nothing worse
than life than living with regret like
like right now i can sit in this chair
and say
i probably gave my motocross me on my
dirt bike 95 percent and the only reason
why that 5 fluctuates is because there
was a time where i started working a
little bit more on a business as i got
older or
focusing a little bit more time on my
relationship with my wife but i can say
for a certain period of time it was a
hundred percent and at worst case it was
95. and now i sit here with no regrets
you know there were periods of my career
that i didn't love like after i did my
first backflip and then the pressure
and the elevation that the sport had and
how i would i basically had a
i had a system of either i was going to
get a medal or i was going to leave on a
stretcher like that was my that was my
career at that point and i didn't like
that part of it but sitting here in this
chair now
i ride i still ride three days a week i
absolutely love it it's not pulling
teeth to get me on my dirt bike i'm
looking forward to the races on and the
photo shoots i'm gonna do this summer
yeah and i've i've worked hard enough to
where i can be this is the most
enjoyable part of my career because i
don't know i don't have a gun in my head
i'm making money still yeah and i'm
enjoying myself but but but you've you
you've also you know like the first
business was really tattoos right yeah
so like and then that like
blossomed to this like huge [ __ ] line
tv shows like the whole thing right it
like blew the [ __ ] up like when you
first started that that came out of an
injury that came out of like you being
injured and not really
you sort of not what was it like not not
having like energy to you not not being
able to direct your energy towards a
certain place well that's what's funny
so again you know kind of everything
happens for a reason i got i was moving
forward on doing my tattoo shop and it
was just going to be a passion project
you know obviously i love getting
tattoos i lived in vegas so i wasn't
open this little tattoo shop as a
passion project so i was you know have
something to make a little bit more
money on and i had that injury on tony
hawk tour so basically what i thought it
was going to be a career-ending injury
you know like i told you it took me six
months to even be able to walk on my own
two legs out of a wheelchair
so i immersed myself in that business
like at that point my life my motocross
career was over you know i had a couple
of contracts a little bit of money in
the bank and i had to pivot i had to
make something else happen and what's
driving you there like for you to go 100
into being like okay i'm gonna be an
entrepreneur i'm gonna i'm gonna like
focus everything into this like what
what is it to win is it to be successful
i mean i don't wanna sound shallow
because obviously you know we all have
to have careers have jobs um you know
what i knew i didn't wanna do
which is as much as as important as my
upbringing was to me i didn't want to go
back to living in las vegas doing
asphalt for my old man and that's
something that he ingrained in me he's
like i can i mean was there really any
chance of that then
i mean who knows you know i mean like
but that's the pressure i put on myself
and then that's that's that switch in my
head is like i don't want to go back to
what i was i don't want to go back to
what my destiny probably would have been
had i not been successful in motocross
no i'm sure i would have done something
else but that's the drive that kind of
would snap me into whatever my pivot was
going to be but then there's also
you know i want to do i want work to be
fun i want to love my job right like i
don't want to drag my ass out of bed on
monday and be miserable until friday
after work you know i watched my dad do
that my entire life right so there was a
lot of motivations but obviously you
know being successful and making money
and and sustaining a lifestyle was one
of them but then there was also like i'm
i i don't want to just do the same thing
everybody's doing i want to do it
different and i want to do it the best
and i want to make it the biggest and i
want to create so many avenues off of
that one opportunity i want to see what
i can grow this into yeah and that was
really kind of my challenge like i love
to be challenged and there is a lot of
business opportunities where i mean look
i'm going to tell you i've taken my
licks and learned the hard way you know
even through my tattoo business on
paperwork and con contracts that have
cost me like a college education and a
learning lesson
but it was just that drive to do
something different and something new
and something better and something
bigger and when you're starting
something new like that i mean like look
man the impetus for for this for me was
was literally just being like really
just sort of frustrated with discourse
surrounding honestly the the kind of
national conversation
after uh george floyd was killed yeah
you know absolutely horrified and
disgusted with what i saw but also not
want to throw bottles at police officers
like i couldn't i couldn't understand
why i couldn't have that attitude and
and then i just thought of all like the
wonderful people that i knew and i was
like [ __ ] man i want to hear what they
think and i want to bring them on and uh
there's gray everything isn't black and
white there's gray yeah exactly you have
to be on one side of the fence
well there's nothing honest i mean i
think that like fundamentalism is like
the opposite of of of of honesty and i
think it's also like the opposite of
what we try to do in this country it's
all about discourse and compromise and
respect and hey you might think
differently than me but you don't scare
me like you can we can talk they can be
cool at 100 we can have a beer and like
completely disagree and like agree that
we like love our families and i want
what's best for your family you know
what's best for mine because we live in
the greatest country on earth and and um
i just don't know kind of where that
went um my driver i guess is more
towards bringing on the kind of people i
would want my kids to listen to yeah i'm
just wondering like for you i mean i
think you you know you sort of have this
innate unbelievable understanding of of
marketing and and you know you're
amazing on camera it's like you're going
into these worlds where you you didn't
know much about i would imagine and it's
like when you go into those things it's
like [ __ ] man i i know what i'm doing or
is it like i mean you have a vision like
so how do you how do you go through that
you know everything that i've done has
started as a passion you know tattooing
i love tattoos i love hanging out in
tattoo shops they were kind of like my
barber shop you know and uh i just
didn't feel that most of them were done
well so i rolled the dice this was going
to be a passion project for me due to
injuries i focused on it 100
and i took my licks you know and that
was the great thing about when we did
ink because it was just about
this stupid motorcycle rider who opened
a tattoo shop in a casino and fly on the
wall and let's see if i can make this
thing happen you know i took my licks
you know like bad partner bad
partnerships and costing me millions of
dollars to buy him out and all these
things like i took my licks but it's
just
it's also that drive too like i love
being the underdog i love waking up in
the morning knowing that i gotta go claw
my way to the top and because when you
get to the top of that mount it's just
gonna be that much sweeter
so it it was always it's exciting you
know like there's something exciting
about rolling the dice on a bad [ __ ]
idea and then seeing if you come out
good on the back side of it i don't know
that goes back to i think like the way
we're trying to raise up these kids too
yeah
you know like don't don't don't run away
from that like that's not a reason to
run away like run towards that no take
it head on [ __ ] run towards that yeah
and um
i want to [ __ ] with one of these things
real quick dude yeah you got to try
these yeah will you just tell me about
it real quick so uh i think there's a
time and a place for pharmaceuticals um
but i feel that you know we're talking
about our world our country our planet
and medications and what people kind of
deal with to kind of get through their
day-to-day so this stuff feel free i've
been working with this company for a
while and i absolutely swear by it so
you know as we've been having these
conversations whether it's through the
concussions that i've had or just the
high pressures of life being responsible
for children i deal a lot with stress
and anxieties and you know i get a
little
you know i dabble a little bit in
depression and what i love about these
things is it's all holistic you know
it's just kava and you know different
plant medicine it helps with
inflammation it's great motivator to get
in the gym it's a great recovery but
more for what it does for like my head
space
if i'm anxious stressed whatever it's
just an instant mood changer like you
know talking about our kids every day
you know i'm with big b down in my shop
and dealing with the trials and
tribulations of building motorcycles and
uh so
right before i head to the house about a
half hour by throw up to the house i'm
in a grumpy mood i'm bad i've been on
conference calls all day i whack one of
these and i'm like dad of the year cause
i'm in there like i'm engaged with my
kids i'm not looking at my phone so no i
wanted to bring you some of these
because it's just a great option to you
know
whether it's the energy drink craze or
you know i'm just a firm believer is if
you can steer around the you know the
pharmaceuticals as much as possible it
doesn't hurt i appreciate it man yeah
it's not that it tastes pretty good
actually man
it's an acquired taste like some people
you know some people have a hard time
with it you know for big b if it's not
like jelly flavored
stuff yeah but uh
yeah it just kind of takes the edge off
stuff and kind of helps you get a little
chatty and [ __ ] relaxes you [ __ ] i
like that yeah so yeah let me know what
you think yeah yeah i like that
and uh i i guess um
you know i also just wanted to talk
about um you know man like look dude
you're [ __ ]
you you know you're you're like this
like super famous elite [ __ ] athlete
you did and then like you're in her
[ __ ] world dude yeah yeah you're and
like uh
that's [ __ ] great man you know what
i'll actually uh i think a big
you know me and my wife have been
together for 20 years yeah us too which
is pretty monumental in our you know
well your your world and especially with
me and my wife and uh you know i learned
at a very young age where you know i
thought i was
you know big [ __ ] big fish in a little
pond and i remember the first is like
you know vmas or something like that i
went to with her on a red carpet you
know this was like
six months after i did my first backflip
and i was just on you know johnny or not
johnny cars about david letterman you're
like
[ __ ] feeling myself
and i remember going on that red carpet
and everyone's like hey hey corey corey
look this way and i'm like oh no it's
carrie hey casey over here and then hey
can we get a single of pink by yourself
and i'm standing over there holding our
purse like
oh okay i mean i feel that i've always
done a pretty good job of being humble
yeah but that experience when you're at
the top of the totem pole in your world
and you get knocked down 15 levels it's
like oh okay yeah man i need to be aware
of how i'm treating people and how i'm
acting because my [ __ ] still stinks yeah
yeah yeah and i'm not that is cool you
know i'm not that cool and a lot of
people get caught up in that yeah man
and you know man i could feel that i
could feel just a at your place first of
all you know man i'll be honest with you
like i'm not like when i went to uh when
i went to your place first time i was
like
[ __ ] dude i was like god damn dude being
a [ __ ] motor motorcross pays well
like holy [ __ ] dude in there and yeah
i had no idea you know you know who your
wife was and all that but like the first
thing that kind of like became like
super apparent was just like how i don't
know everybody it's like your place is
kind of like [ __ ] heaven bro like
everyone's like super kind there and
super happy and everybody knows each
other and there's a really cool there's
a really kind of cool and beautiful vibe
i mean like you must be just like
enormously proud man i mean let's just
be like like
because when we first met i mean from
like the story i just told you she was
much more popular than me on a grand
scope but when we first met she lived in
a little 800 square foot apartment in
venice beach
and you know our first date or one of
our first few dates when she came to
vegas to spend the weekend with me you
know i picked her up in the airport you
know i had a big old lifted f-250 truck
you know motocross guy and
took her to my house in vegas you know i
was store sort of about the peak of my
financial career at that point and my my
you know my wife now we pull up to my
house she's like what do you still live
with your parents and i'm like no that's
my house what are you talking about
because i was i didn't kind of connect
all the dots and then shortly after that
i went to her apartment in venice but
you know i watched her come up you know
i watched her start to get her feet
under her and not not even you know from
the money aspect but like fine tune
herself from being this little rough
girl from philly kind of r b into this
you know she built herself into this you
know rock power you know female strong
well-rounded musician and i i watched
her tune that yeah in tune her persona
and who she is yeah yeah so like i
literally watched her grow as a musician
me and my wife we grew up together man
like you know when when i met my wife i
was like bouncing at a bar i was like
you you know i was like pretty much
you know i was still sort of a [ __ ] bag
i mean i had this dream but we we kind
of came up together and her she was a
nurse and she was sort of like paying my
way through and we we were we were um
you know we've been we've been we've
been through it together
you guys have a understanding i would
imagine of like what it means to be like
a bit of a public person and like what
are the complications that come with
that and like what what are the ways
that that's like a benefit
i mean i think just the tricky part is
is we live very big business
professional lives and it is kind of
hard to manage and that does
kind of get involved in our personal
life from an aspect of it's like well as
as normal as we feel that we are away
from our day jobs you know we want to
plan a trip to disneyland it doesn't
always go as planned you know one funny
story my last x games
willow was a year old so nine years ago
you know been training preparing for it
all that kind of fun stuff and you know
and she was oh she was very supportive
because you know when i'm training for a
van it's very time consuming so i go i
you know we're at the staples center i
have my last contest finished fourth or
fifth at the event you know big afro
party for me all this fun stuff we go
back to the hotel room
go to bed at like three o'clock in the
morning you know nanny's in the room
with our daughter until we got home and
you know six o'clock in the morning uh
willa starts crying
you know i'm thinking like dude i'm a
little banged up a little sore i just
competed the night before and she elbows
me she's like [ __ ] x games is over go
get that kid and i'm just like
i don't even get a 24 hour porch pass
and it's like get your ass up get back
on dad duty she's like i just did mom
duty while you're training for this
event and
that's what you know i think is like
kind of the equalizer yeah yeah that's
beautiful man and what about uh what
about big b man
what about you know like he's suspect
he's that [ __ ] man
just talk a little bit about your your
friendship and and and kind of like
you know i
i don't know i i just think um for me
there's there's uh there's nothing
that's more important to me than than my
family and my friends and it seems like
you you're from the same cloth what is
it about your your guys friendship and
like what does he mean to you oh man me
and big b have been friends for
25 years now um you know and i probably
much like you i have a really small
circle of friends no don't get me wrong
i have acquaintances and you know but uh
but my true true friends is a very small
circle and they're all long-term friends
and you know me and bigby been friends
for 25 years and it was it was it's
funny because you know motorcross is my
day job his day job is he's a rapper
he's a musician
and we became friends through our
lifestyles in the motocross community
you know a lot of motocross videos were
using his music we're from vegas you
know and that's really what kind of
sparked our friendship and me and him
kind of grew up and
you know off together we we have a great
tight circle and i wouldn't change any
of it for the world [ __ ] amen that's
beautiful what do you worry about dude
like what are you afraid of failure
uh-huh failure and disappointment uh-huh
disappointment being disappointed okay
you know disappointing or failing my
kids is being you know a father
failing or disappointing my partner
being my wife same thing with my friends
and in business and in
career failing you know like that's
always been my driving forces to fail
like whatever that might be whether it's
you know just not getting to the goal or
you know monetary or success-wise
whatever it's just failure and how do
you deal with it when it comes
you gotta take your licks and learn from
it and be i feel be humble um i've i've
made a lot of bad decisions in life and
business and relationships and you learn
from it
you know not a non-narcissist will learn
from that fix that and move forward and
i try to do just that [ __ ] a are you
good man you don't even want to talk
about anything else man you like
yeah actually i want to ask you
questions you can ask me what i want
so
you know we've talked about family and
you know your wife and your relationship
so how do you manage
whether it's the calendar
stepping offset back to being dad
husband like how do you manage that
because at least for me
it's these snippets like i said it's
it's a weekend of motocross racing or
it's you know alicia's on stage for two
and a half hours a night i mean you have
to immerse yourself into a character you
have to change
your mentality and your being and your
mannerisms like how do you balance that
um it's uh look man
you're way better at this than i am dude
that that's a that's a great that like
is the question right and not not
necessarily knowing the answer is is
kind of the answer i i do the best i
[ __ ] can and and and i i know that i
like live by this coda
of just really being where the [ __ ] you
are while you're there yeah um
you know a lot of the time the way i
work whether it's fortunate or
unfortunate um is this full immersion
you know and um sometimes dangerously so
and and not to get too [ __ ]
you know cheese dick hoodie toy actor
[ __ ] but like i do man i i i give
everything to it and i'm so great like i
couldn't have a family i couldn't have
my wife i couldn't have my kids i would
be that same [ __ ] up if it wasn't for
this so i put everything into this the
only other thing in my life that i feel
that level of sort of like uh
sacredness is is is my family and i i
it's it's these two things so you know
one answer for sure is trim fat like do
not take on do not do do do you know cut
out relationships that get in the way of
either of those things the big problem
with me man is that like you know i go
into these
jobs these projects
and i immerse so deeply that i connect
with these
these communities
and i get enormously close with people
and i think the problem is then the
project's over and i'm not the kind of
guy that's just going to be like yo dude
like you you you know i got into your
life i've been in your cell i've been in
your home i've been in your church i've
been in your kitchen and now i can't
[ __ ] with you anymore so it does um i'm
i'm i'm super grateful for it because
it's built this like rich rich
tapestry of unbelievable relationships
which which just being an [ __ ] puts
on makeup and says lions for a living
has given me entry way into people
opening up and sharing their life with
me which i like that that [ __ ] is sacred
i treasure that um
but
yeah man it's it's um you know normally
you know my kind of
uh process is you know getting on
getting in my truck with my dogs and
like driving whether it's arizona new
mexico atlanta new york getting there
yeah being there the whole [ __ ] time
being in a hundred percent and then kind
of driving back and using that drive to
sort of shed that [ __ ] yeah man and get
back um look man i have gotten to a
point now where i i just um i i can't
miss any more
you know here and um
i do have more peace of mind now than
i've ever had
you know trimming so much fat off and
being here there but but uh i'm still on
that [ __ ] chase and i'm i'm i'm i'm
uh i'm cool with it yeah i figured it
was hard because you know like i first
got exposed to you through walking dead
and then seeing the punisher and wolf of
wall street and then the
serena williams project it's like i
figured you have to be that immersive of
a person because you can't be as good as
you are by phoning it yeah and
i just i mean but it's like the same
thing like i wouldn't you know look man
like i wouldn't want to
you know like i i just like i don't want
it to be easy and it's not that it's
look man if i could just walk up and and
and kind of like walk like john like
there's some people who like are on
their [ __ ] phones on set and they can
just [ __ ] like
you know like i just i don't have the
balls to even try that man it's just
like i've got to go well you know what
works for you i think like you men i
wouldn't i wouldn't change it for the
world you know what i mean yeah yeah
yeah well i'm very impressed by like i
said we've known each other a short time
but
your craft on screen your personal life
your priorities you as a person i mean
you know like me and big b have talked
about it you know especially after you
met big b the the last time coming down
i mean you're one of us which is fun
because in this new day and age of
people and
and priorities and well-being it's like
you come across them very very uh very
rarely so yeah yeah i feel appreciate
who you are and the person that you are
thank you man i feel the same way man
like just a total total respect and and
admiration for both of you guys yeah
it's it's uh i'm grateful dude all right
well when you slow down we're gonna go
ride some motorcycles we'll definitely
ride some motorcycles yeah man that
would be uh it'll be great dude that'd
be great thank you for doing this too
all good thank you for having me
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff and mean a lot to us i
hope you dig these episodes as much as
we dig doing them you guys take care of
yourself